hello guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm
Breanna white written Ryan Wright
Breanna white yeah it's right and white
the right like the color like being
white is right also be white be Yui as
it's right we're gonna check out porn
stars read mean comments number one and
number two let's get to this port of
rosser's yeah that's good one now jimmy
kimmel have done quite a few videos
where he had celebrities read me toots
yes not teamed up with NBA players NFL
players actors and even musicians but
he's missing a category mm-hmm so we
teamed up with grassers and poor enough
to bring you yes Rogers pornstars Reed
mean comments on pornhub
gotta love porn I hate Johnny sins bald
head but he always rails the most
attractive girls decisions decisions
about what whether you want to watch
attractive girls get real nasty nipple
please no more scenes with her did
something already tell her that her
tattoo has got a spelling mistake
presence you spend a million dollars on
his [ __ ] I paid 1 million for him to
shut up
this has a stupid vibe to her look
please shave you could be so hot but the
hairs are a total turnoff please shave
hopefully she shaves that tuft of hair
goes to a cleaner look the 70s are over
I left my woman fur okay good I don't
like looking like three-year-olds I hate
Johnny sands but he always rails the
hottest girls so it's hard not to watch
him and his mr. clean head UK he's most
annoying export did someone ever wanted
to use her ass as a pillow
well yeah everybody does in use
[ __ ] we used to fake it good to
know that my skin doesn't look like
leather anymore when I look into your
butthole
I see diapers into your future the only
thing bigger than you is how can you
know in you all man she lost her
voluptuous body type she lost what made
her great someone get this just embraces
and then we'll talk it was I got that
call she was a little back - trash gotta
love a keyboard warrior pepperoni tips
your forehead is more like a seven head
okay everyone seven head is
thank you for watching the video
oh we're gonna wash your second video
now buddy here we go dude real fast
Bonnie rotten one of my favorites she's
so hot so hot I like the tattoo that
hair Oh daddy's are pretty hot yeah I
wouldn't I don't know if I'd ever date a
girl like Bonnie Iran but someone I'm
watching her movies yeah not good movies
totally I mean there's way difference a
huge difference between like girlfriend
and porn star
yeah absolutely the two guys they aren't
a lot of porn videos oh really
they're in a lot of porn videos well I
guess that's why they chose them there's
three females you know that just would
be totally sexist yeah it would be but
these guys have huge dicks and it's good
to watch them totally
Johnny sins is way more cut though hmm
I mean I'd rather watch him but he is
bald and it can be distracting
I'm sure he's bald everywhere oh wow
it's pretty impressive just like one of
those like Sphinx cat yeah
Mike I just want to hug him here we go
yo what's going on guys are chetan yeah
so you watched part one you loved part
one can't beg for a party
so once again we teamed up for grasses
at pornhub to bring you something epic
again Rises porn stars reading comments
on born apart or - that's my life time
better put these my life cars go
on one hand eric Eberhard looks like a
douchebag on the other hand
Eric Earhart looks like a douchebag if
you say
Abigail Mac three times in a mirror she
shows up and disappoints you just like
her scenes do oh so what part of your
personality did you have to give up to
get a big was it intelligence I really
understand the question you know the
shame you should feel lips that would
make Donald Duck Pro these are stuff I
hope you're not sponsored by PETA
because I want to pound the [ __ ] out of
your beaver
you are the Nickelback of male porn
stars it's a long one more more more
more more more more more more more why
is that your voice sounds like that of a
xxx old man more more more more more
more more more more MORE
is it me or does Danny D have the most
punchable face important I don't really
care to be honest right there's not many
people punch me in the face
more and more ^ 10 you look like high
school was the peak of your life
outrageous Stevie Wonder's favorite porn
star ladies and gentlemen we have the
first person to dirty for a Wall Street
stop smiling Johnny you're bald bald
people aren't happy how does it feel to
know that guys like your boyfriend more
than you her mounts
are less realistic than Johnny sends as
a doctor
you are the human representation of
Florida oh that's rough
Eric Eberhard clever name douchebag
well considering that my always stays
hard yeah it is pretty clever
something seems fishy about Chanel maybe
it sir just like she was getting on Wall
Street so she decided the best
alternative was to do porn and literally
get hot I mean doesn't that sound good
to you bro
how the hell do you pronounce your Feeny
PETA petaa get your together solid porn
name sounds like your Barbie friend that
nobody cares about
Phoenix Marie is like my spirit my
spirit animal is a lazy honey
eating bear whose words PETA from The
Hunger Games or PETA from browsers why
not both whoop-dee-doo you worked on
Wall Street
clearly that worked out for you now that
you're in porn well gee I wonder how
your virginity is working out yeah
pretty sure you're missing an end on
your last name who has more people in
the Stasi car or an overcrowded prison
you be the judge you remind me of a
Soviet villain from an 80s d-list action
movie my brain says no but my says yes
I'm gonna go somebody and you guys can
sit there and whack off how does it feel
to know your boyfriend hotter chicks
than you it feels a little bit like go
[ __ ] yourself
Wow okay yeah I love seeing porn stars
when they're not in porn because you
could see their personality totally
you're like these are just real people
who just happen to do porn every time
every time I've ever bummed if someone
is out of trying to be in porn has done
something before they're just like it's
always an act in the porno but then you
see that they're like kind of
professional about it like it's just a
job they're doing just like anyone else
yeah it's like everyone has sex they
just get paid to show themselves having
sex exactly I really like how well they
dealt with these things yeah you know
like I'm sure they don't read comments
on their daily basis but I'm sure they
hear these things there's really
ignorant people out there trying to make
them feel awful about themselves and
they just you know have really thick
skins and they just deal with it there
are people who are obviously bothered
too but the one that you can tell when
they're not bothered and I totally you
know it's like it's hard to get to a
point where you're not bothered by it
but yeah I guess if you're going into
porn yet you really do got to develop
thick skin in order to handle it if you
don't you wouldn't be doing something
like this video yeah exactly
exactly jeopardy porn no really never
never struck me as the kind no I don't
[ __ ]
something about your personality what's
wrong with you I'm just joking I'm just
joking don't do porn it's a sin it's not
a sin it's just not for me
well Christians might disagree with you
okay they have the right to but I'm just
saying like porn stars have every right
to do what they do there's nothing wrong
with it it's just not Oprah Brianna no
just dope don't do it I'm joking she
looks at you with those evil eyes evil
oh my god everything I'm saying it's
just like I'm digging that grave anyway
guys if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects you
could check out Briana White's channel
in the meantime more videos coming
hopefully by the end of this week
actually and you in meantime you can
follow our Facebook page where
appropriate comment insert here
yes and you can follow real rejects on
Facebook Instagram Twitter vine a
periscope
Anthony Gentilly or Gentile Gentile okay
I'll you're [ __ ] hilarious Ryan you
[ __ ] you're a [ __ ] Anthony I like how
he says it like it's a compliment you
[ __ ]
yeah what the love you see what you look
like Anthony oh you're just a little kid
you're slip to you what is up with this
it's a really old picture and maybe he's
like gonna find out I know he's not he's
the most late his latest photos no okay
okay he's like it music a teenager maybe
listen we just watched a very important
video Anthony you have access to the
Internet
I'm telling you there's more than just
pornhub and browsers out there there's
red tube
there's 69 calm there's xvideos XXX
videos xhamster they're pretty good they
feature a lot of weird [ __ ] though like
like videos I don't really like to watch
punished to calm um what come on you
know something this just goes on and you
know something right you know some point
I already listed all the ones that I
know do you ever watch porn cuz Anthony
would love to watch porn with you I'm
not gonna talk about that you're not
gonna talk about watching part of the
Anthony easy too young
yeah is that the only reasonable isn't
not the only reason why I'm sorry I mean
I tried helping you maybe one day he'll
watch porn with Briana no really never
do you ever watch porn you've got to
calm down